[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Samstagabend ihnen allen das
Schwarze Meer wird immer mehr zum
Kriegsschauplatz wir haben Drohnen als
Waffe ja bereits kennenlernen müssen die
russische Armee setzt sie seit vielen
Monaten massiv gegen zivile Ziele in der
Ukraine ein jetzt intensiviert die
Ukraine ihre Attacken mit Drohnen auf
See erst traf es ein russisches
Marineschiff in seiner Basis jetzt einen
russischen Tanker die Botschaft soll
sein während Russland das Seegebiet
weiterhin kontrolliert kann es sich
nicht mehr sicher fühlen Laura Panik
berichtet
mit mehreren hundert Kilogramm
Sprengstoff beladen attackiert diese
se-drohne den russischen Öltanker Sieg
in der Meerenge von Kersch bei dem
Angriff wird der Maschinenraum schwer
beschädigt bereits kurz vorher sollen
ähnliche Aufnahmen einen Angriff der
Ukraine auf ein russisches Kriegsschiff
zeigen die Bilder veröffentlicht von der
ukrainischen Marine haben eine klare
Botschaft diese Drohnen kommen
ungehindert ohne dass er sozusagen eine
Verteidigungslinie aufgebaut ist bis zu
den Schiffen durch und können sie
zerstören das ist ja alles in allem
schon eine ein schwerer Schlag ins
Kontor für die schwarze Flotte hier
vermeldet die Angriffe sein erfolgreich
gewesen der Sprecher des Militär
Geheimdienstes kündigt im ukrainischen
Fernsehen an weiter Schiffe die Material
für Russlands Militär transportieren
anzugreifen
die Ukraine droht die Angriffe entlang
der russischen Küste auszuweiten und
erklärt sechs helfen zwischen der Krim
und der georgischen Grenze zum
kriegsrisikogebiet neben der
militärischen Bedrohung könnte das
Russland vor allem wirtschaftlich
Schwächen in dem Moment in dem ich ein
Gebiet für ein kriegsrisikogebiet
erkläre gehen normalerweise Versicherer
hin und versichern nichts mehr und
natürlich könnte das ein Problem für die
russische Versorgung werden
Russland bemüht sich um Normalität und
veröffentlicht heute Bilder die
Verteidigungsminister scheugr an der
Front in dorniez zeigen sollen die
Richtigkeit der Angaben lässt sich nicht
überprüfen russland hat Vergeltung für
die Jüngsten ukrainischen Attacken
angekündigt
in jedda Saudi-Arabien wollen etwa 40
Staaten heute und morgen nach einer
Friedenslösung suchen China ist dabei
Russland aber nicht eingeladen soll die
Arabien pflegt ja gute Kontakte sowohl
zu Russland als auch zur Ukraine
Teil beobachtet das für uns goldene
guten Abend wie groß kann denn jetzt die
Hoffnung sein dass dabei auch etwas
wegweisendes herauskommt
also das Treffen in Schüler ist mehr
informeller Natur ist es bislang auch
kein einziges Bild vom Treffen in die
Öffentlichkeit gedrungen es geht auch
nicht um einen Durchbruch es geht mehr
darum ein Prozess anzustoßen die Ukraine
hat vor der Welt ihren friedensbahn
vorgestellt für sie ist schon der
Austragungsort ein Erfolg die Welt
sammelt sich um die Ukraine in einem
Land des Global in Südens beim
weltgrößten Ölexporteur das konnte das
russische narrativ und nach die Ukraine
nur westliche Unterstützer habe und der
Gastgeber Saudi-Arabien der profitiert
sich wieder einmal als geopolitischer
Player als Mittelmacht mit guten
Beziehungen zu beiden Seiten das
verfolgt humanitäre Ziele in diesem
Krieg zum Beispiel ein weiteren
Gefangenenaustausch und es kann sich
rühmen China an den Tisch gebracht zu
haben das jetzt die vielen neutralen
Länder wie z.B Indien wie zum Beispiel
die afrikanischen Staaten jetzt
plötzlich dort auf die Idee kommen
Sanktionen gegen Russland zu
unterstützen das ist unrealistisch es
geht eher darum eine Art globalen
Konsens zu finden für die einzelnen
Punkte einer möglichen Lösung die dann
auch für die Ukraine annehmbar wäre
herzlichen Dank für diese Einschätzung
heute Abend live aus Kairo
seit mehr als drei Jahrzehnten seit
Slowenien unabhängig ist hat es dort
keine solche Naturkatastrophe gegeben
wie aktuell es sind die schlimmsten
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutsche in der
Geschichte des Landes nach heftigen
Unwettern auch in Kärnten und der
Steiermark in Österreich gibt es keine
Entwarnung und Kroatien muss sich auf
eine Flutwelle vorbereiten Wolf
Christian Ulrich hat mehr
es ist eine Naturkatastrophe wie sie
Slowenien in seiner jüngeren Geschichte
noch nicht erlebt hat noch immer retten
Hilfskräfte mit dem Hubschrauber
Menschen aus Dörfern die von der
Außenwelt abgeschnitten sind mindestens
vier Tote sind zu beklagen fünf
Touristen werden vermisst tausende
Menschen bleiben ohne Trinkwasser Strom
und Telefon
ich mache mir Sorgen um meine Familie
sagt dieser Mann ich kann Sie
telefonisch nicht erreichen
noch in der Nacht wurden Campingplätze
evakuiert Touristen in Sicherheit
gebracht sie fanden Notunterkunft in
Schulen und Turnhallen
wir haben nur das nötigste gepackt und
sind los wir können dem Zivilschutz und
der Feuerwehr gar nicht genug danken sie
haben sich so gut um uns gekümmert
überall heute das große Aufräumen laut
der Regierung leiden zwei Drittel aller
slowenischen Gemeinden unter den Folgen
von Flut und Erdrutschen
der Stadt wird nicht genug Hilfe leisten
können wir müssen uns allen als Nachbarn
helfen von Mensch zu Mensch und so
werden wir dieses größte Desaster
unserer Geschichte meistern in Ordnung
auch die Wirtschaft ist schwer getroffen
Bahnlinien und Straßen vielerorts und
passierbar ganz Industriegebiete
zerstört mindestens 500 Millionen Euro
Schaden erheblich für ein Land mit nur
zwei Millionen Einwohnern die EU
versprach Hilfe Schäden auch im
benachbarten Österreich nach starken
Regenfällen sind Straßen und Häuser
überflutet vereinzelt gab es
Evakuierungen
schauen dass die ganzen Leid in
Sicherheit haben und dort wo als Wasser
unter Umständen zurückkehren sondern den
an oder anderen Keller doch trocken
bringen während sich die Lage in
Österreich beruhigt bereitet man sich
weiter südlichen Kroatien auf eine
Flutwelle vor dort steigen die
Pegelstände bereits
und noch dieser Hinweis der Behörden und
Automobilclubs auf wichtigen Urlaubs-
und transit-routen Richtung Kroatien
kommt das aktuell zu massiven
Behinderungen und vielen Staus so der
Überblick über die weitere Weltlage
jetzt von Diana mit Blick auf den
Militärputsch in Niger hat Frankreich
sich hinter die westafrikanische
Staatengemeinschaft ecovas gestellt die
Bemühungen den Putschversuch abzuwehren
würden mit Entschlossenheit unterstützt
erklärte das französische
Außenministerium dabei wurden keine
Angaben dazu gemacht ob dies auch
militärische Mittel umfasst ECOWAS hatte
eine gewaltsame Intervention angekündigt
sollte der entmachtete Präsident bei
Zoom bis morgen Abend nicht wieder im
Amt sein die
militär-plan dazu sei bereits
ausgearbeitet worden
nur wenige Monate vor den
Parlamentswahlen in Pakistan ist der
ehemalige Premierminister Kahn wegen
Korruptionsvorwürfen zu drei Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt und festgenommen
worden durch das Urteil könnte er für
fünf Jahre von politischen Ämtern
ausgeschlossen werden in mehreren
Städten kam es zu kleineren Protesten
von Unterstützern kannst nachdem dieser
kurz nach der Urteilsverkündung selbst
dazu aufgerufen hatte kam bezeichnet die
Vorwürfe als politisch motiviert seine
Anwälte kündigten Berufung an
beim Weltjugendtag in Portugal hat der
Papst heute den Wallfahrtsort Fatima
besucht und betont die Kirche müsse
offen für alle sein vor etwa 200.000
Gläubigen betete der Pontifex zudem für
Frieden auf der Welt am Abend fand in
Lissabon dann eine große Andacht zur
nächtlichen Gebetswache mit
hunderttausenden Gläubigen statt morgen
geht der Weltjugendtag zu Ende
sie waren 11 Mal deutscher Meister
zusammengenommen und es ist lange her
heute treffen sich die beiden in einer
zweiten Liga die dermaßen von
klangvollen Namen strotzt dass sie fast
wie die erste wirkt Schalke gegen
Kaiserslautern die Arena auf Schalke
dementsprechend ausverkauft 62.000
Zuschauer das letzte Mal trafen sich
beide Clubs vor über 11 Jahren in der
Bundesliga damals gewann Schalke 0:1 bis
heute ausging
62.000 Fans in der ausverkauften Schalke
Arena sehen den besseren Start für die
Gäste die Roten Teufel in selbigen
Trikots über Marlon Ritter aber der
Mittelfeldspieler scheitern dadurch 4
Minuten an einer glänzenden Parade des
Schalker Schlussmanns Marius Müller 0:0
dank des Schalke Keepers aber nicht
lange denn Schalke geht's nach 13
Minuten in Führung durch wen natürlich
durch Simon Terodde Treffer Nummer 174
in Liga 2 vorbereitet durch den
Linksverteidiger Uwe Jahn und noch eine
schöne Zeit für die Rolle im 9 Duell mit
Kaiserslautern trifft er schon zum
achten Mal gegen die Pfälzer die
unterschiedlichen Gefühlswelten der
beiden Coaches und für die Schuster den
Trainer der Lauterer wird's nicht besser
5 Minuten vor der Pause wagt sein Pieper
Andreas lute einen Ausflug und der wird
richtig teuer glatt Rot für den Lauterer
Keeper und das geht völlig in Ordnung
klares faul an Schalkes Uwe Jan lute
geht's 36 Jahre alt seit 23 schwieriger
Ersatzmann Julian Krahl kommt das
schmeckt Schalke denn Lautern in
Unterzahl und es wird 8 Minuten nach
Wiederbeginn noch schlimmer für die
Pfälzer Boris tomiak klammert gegen
Brunner lauter nur noch mit neun Mann
auf dem Platz und null zu eins in
Rückstand Königsblau legt sich nun den
Gegner zurecht und profitiert von einem
üblen Ausrutscher des Lauterer Keepers
Kenan Karaman ist der Nutznießer das 2:0
in der 70 Minute Schalke 04 auf der
Siegerstraße das Ergebnis geht auch in
Ordnung aber ein maroder ein übler
abends für lauter Sache war durch aber
ein echter Pfälzer lässt sich von sowas
nicht unterkriegen den Schlusspunkt
setzt dann Brian lass mich der Neuzugang
aus Bielefeld in Minuten 90 + 2 er
nagelt den Ball unhaltbar unter dem
Querbalken Schalke 04 besiegt den ersten
fC Kaiserslautern mit 3:0 und feiert den
ersten Sieg in dieser Saison
die zweite Liga gespickt mit
Traditionsklubs steuert auf einen
zuschauerboom wir haben noch weitere
spannende Partien heute jetzt in der
Zusammenfassung
Elversberg empfängt Rostock jedoch nicht
im heimischen Stadion sondern in
Saarbrücken die eigentliche Heimstätte
des Zweitliga Aufsteigers wird noch
umgebaut die erste nennenswerte
Gelegenheit der Partie für die
Saarländer rochels Freistoß 6 Minute das
Spiel in der ersten Hälfte ausgeglichen
Rostock nach einer halben Stunde dann
mit Kröger Christoph pariert noch mal
pröger
elversbergsabwehr steht
kurz vor der Pause die Saarländer dann
im alu-pech Sickinger nur an die Latte
die zweite Hälfte Eckball Elversberg
erst fagier per Kopf dann stoppt
Sickinger ab 55 Minute 1:0 für die
Saarländer sehr zu Freude ihres Trainers
Horst Steffen die letzten Minuten haben
es dann in sich Rostock singenfeld in
Schnellbacher es gibt Strafstoß für
Elversberg Rochelt tritt an Kolke
pariert aber da der Elversberger bei der
Ausführung zu früh in den Strafraum
startet zählt das Tor zu Recht nicht auf
der Gegenseite die Gäste eiskalt der
eingewechselte Neuzugang peria in der 10
Minute danach Spielzeit zum Ausgleich 3
Minuten später dreht Hanse das Spiel
peria mit dem 2:1 für Stock feiert einen
späten und spektakulären Sieg gegen
Elversberg
Greuther Fürth als Tabellenführer nach
Kiel gereist in den weiß-grünen Trikots
in der ersten Halbzeit von rechts nach
links und mit der besten Möglichkeit
durch Julian green etwas mehr als eine
halbe Stunde da gespielt torlos geht es
in die Kabine dann der Patzer von Kiel
Torhüter Denner Gotha sagt Danke Schön
63 Minute der Schwede profitiert vom
panzertes Holstein Keepers
nur 5 Minuten später aber die Antwort
der Kieler durch Sterne nach tolle
Hereingabe von BVB Leihgabe Tom rote und
wieder nur eine Minute später sie mal
color mit dem Traumhaus für marcino der
geht zu Boden es gibt 11 Meter der
gefaltete tritt selbst dann
machino mit dem 2:1 entstand in der 71
Minute Kiel stürzt den bisherigen
Tabellenführer
das erste Mal Millerntor in dieser
Saison St Pauli in braun gegen
Düsseldorf in weiß es ist aber mehr oder
minder ein Duell der Nummer 7 der
braunen Irvine der Kapitän gegen einen
gelben Kastenmeier in Düsseldorfer Tor
immer wieder dieses Duell auch im
zweiten Durchgang urban mit der besten
Chance der Partie aber Kastenmeier hält
seinen Kasten sauber 7 Minuten vor dem
Ende Düsseldorf mal in der Offensive mit
dem langen gestreckten Bein gegen das
Knie von niemitsch klare Sache das ist
rot Klaus kann die beste Chance auf den
Sieg Treffer aber nicht nutzen so endet
das Spiel 0 zu 0 und beide starten mit
vier Punkten in diese Saison
und jetzt die Lottozahlen von diesem
Samstag die lauten vier 22 23 35 42 49
Superzahl 4 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
fehlt noch der Blick aufs Wetter das
erst ab Mittwoch wieder richtig
sommerlich wird morgen sehr wechselhaft
mit vielen Wolken wenig Sonne und
häufigen Schauern sowie einzelnen
Gewittern im Süden starker Westwind mit
stürmischen Böen 13 bis 21 Grad am
Montag sehr windig und bei 14 bis 20
Grad weiterer Regen am Dienstag im
Norden Schauer an der Seesturm und im
Süden sonnig Mittwoch auf sommerlich bei
19 bis 29 Grad
oft sommerlich wir konzentrieren uns auf
die Woche ab Mittwoch sagen für heute
erstmal Danke und sind gerne morgen
wieder für Sie da wir wünschen Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend tschüss
[Musik]